russ élargi son offensive à l'ouest du
pays à l'ouest de l'ukraine la tour de
télévision de la région de rivne a été
frappé par des russie hier matin il ya
au moins 20 morts parmi les soldats
d'ukrainiens selon les ukrainiens on
retrouve tout de suite justement arrive
n'est gulliver craag notre envoyé
spécial gulliver bonsoir les habitants
j'imagine de la ville de rivne sont de
plus en plus inquiet
oui les habitants de rivne sont nerveux
d'autant plus que les sirènes ont encore
retenti aujourd'hui sans clie des
attaques dans la région confirmée mais
cette attaque de lundi matin sur la tour
de télévision qui ont fait se situe dans
un village à 13 km environ du centre
ville de rivne était d'envergure le
bilan de 30 bardon excusez moi le bilan
est actuellement de 20 morts mais
pourrait
s'aggraver puisque les travaux de
sauvetage sont encore en cours pour le
moment c'est toujours dans l'ouest de
l'ukraine des éléments d'infrastructure
critiques ou des bases militaires qui
sont visés mais ces attaques sont de
plus en plus fréquent en plus de rivne
il y eut cette attaque notamment sur la
base militaire de yaro rives à l'ouest
de la ville et aussi des aéroports et
des aérodromes qui ont été visés à
travers la région de l'ouest et
d'ukraine merci beaucoup gulliver
gulliver craag à harry venait